et nous sommes avec un régis on paie à
la liste géopolitique et directeur
exécutif d'interclubs conseil bonjour je
merci d'être avec nous la france n'est
donc plus un partenaire privilégié de
l'afrique
comment est-ce que vous l'analysez cela
s'explique par le passé colonial par la
question mémorielle aussi très présente
encore dans les mémoires
exactement c'est déclassement de la
france dont justement dans le rang des
grandes puissances en afrique ce peut
s'expliquer à la fois parce que vous
voulez d'évoquer par l'histoire par la
mémoire qui est qu'il reste encore
vivace mais qui n'est pas toujours
assumé du côté français mais surtout il
ya quand même quelques raisons je peux
en retirer au moins trois il ya comme
une des raisons économiques
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le continent
africain s'est ouvert à d'autres acteurs
privés à d'autres puissances économiques
comme la chine la russie et le qatar
mais tout récemment la turquie et plein
d'autres acteurs et puis effectivement
il ya aussi des raisons idéologiques
aujourd'hui pour les entrepôts les
africaines pour le personnel politique
africain certains personnels pour le
théâtre et pour des acteurs du privé
africain aller vers d'autres cieux et
plus intéressant parce que justement on
peut tisser on peut allier des relations
qui sont juillet plus équitable et puis
justement vous vous l'avez évoqué il ya
un tableau aussi un rêve en une raison
ni réseaux politiques
il ya un potentiel politique qui
s'esquisse existe depuis la colonisation
et qui est très vivace qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le soutien de la france
le soutien de la france pour certains je
veux dire en guillemets dictatures
africaines est de moins en moins
acceptée dans ce qui fait que la société
civile africaine la jeunesse africaine
j'ai seulement quelques clairement fait
alliés et cela provoque et donc le
déclassement donc de la puissance
française et et qui est toujours
comprise comme une ancienne colonisation
qui continue malgré les 60 ans
d'indépendance d'avoir quand même la
même liste des secteurs stratégiques et
politiques en afrique
est-ce qu'il ya aussi un mélange des
genres qui conduit à imputer aux
entreprises françaises ce que fait ce
que réalise l'état français exactement
je pense qu'il ya une confusion parce
que l'engagement comme des entreprises
françaises les certes elle est très
important mais n'est plus privilégiés
donc la confusion fp du principe que le
régime français le pouvoir français
parce que on peut le haut pour élever on
peut lire on pourrait nous reprocher
ces actions son soutien jeudi soir à
certains pays africains à ceux des
présidents africains dont quelque part
je voulais c'est un bateau qui font à la
fois le pouvoir français à la fois les
entreprises françaises et quelque part
aussi peut aussi frapper de l'ajustement
les relation que la france entretient
avec d'autres avec l'homme laddh des
sociétés civiles africaines qui sont à
la fois ci le continent africain est
aussi en france entre en compte haussier
on imagine le contexte sécuritaire
la multiplication des attaques au mali
au niger au burkina faso avec ce
sentiment anti français qui monte dans
les opinions publiques de plusieurs pays
du sahel où la france s'est engagée
militairement depuis plusieurs années
dans sa lutte contre contrôle djihadisme
ça aussi ça pèse beaucoup oui mais je je
je je voudrais vous dit la chose
suivante le sentiment français en fait
je pense qu'il est assez la secure est à
se caricaturer l'a fait instrumentalisés
par un sentiment anti français n'y a pas
de francophobie naissant l'afrique
émergente en afrique c'est beaucoup plus
un ressentiment par rapport au régime
par rapport au pouvoir six as if
français qu'ils sont quittes je veux
dire depuis les indépendances se sont
alliés très généralement avec des
pouvoirs qui était contesté en afrique
des pouvoirs contestée et contestable
donc en fait il ya une double ou double
double ravad ou double défiance à la
fois qu'ils frappent à la fois des
pouvoirs africains alliés justement à la
puissance à l'ex puissance coloniale
française dans ce qui fait que la france
est
elle est peut-être incomprise elle est
mal vu dans sept secteurs africain est
alors justement selon vous qu'est
laquelle chantier devraient être engagés
pour améliorer l'image des entreprises
françaises sur le continent africain je
pense qu'il ya toute une gamme à la fois
qui tient à la fois de la communication
et du software moi je pense que les
entreprises françaises devraient
davantage plus à l'est vraiment enfin ça
l'est davantage puisque avec des pme
africaines détail de taille similaire
je pense que allait forcément sous le
choc sous le chapeau ou même le
chapiteau français peut donner
l'impression que ce soit que ce soit
dans le bras économique de la puissance
française qui revient entre guillemets
conquérir des parts de marché africain
alors qu' il y avait un certain que des
entreprises françaises qui veulent
coopérer économique pas avec des
entreprises africaines de façon
équitable de façon respectable je pense
qu'il ya à la fois en respectant le
droit les normes sociales même aussi
même des exigences environnementales je
pense que ça peut ça peut être un
facteur positif pour des coopérations
très juste et très équitable parce que
en armant faut quand même le souvenir la
france reste quand même très implantée
sur le continent africain avec 1100 gros
peu plus de 2000 sont filiales
oui et ce n'est pas anodin mais malgré
tout il ya ce désir oui il ya un désaveu
comme je le dis qui tient à la fois de
l'histoire et a dû aussi du présent mais
aussi du fait que j'ai aujourd'hui
les entrepôts les africains et même très
très léger ramon la jeunesse africaine
qui est très mouvant qui est très
dynamique
un game et s'est découvert d'autres
opportunités la france reste importante
mais aujourd'hui on est plus dans le
choeur si vous voulez le coeur
privilégié quand même les relations
entre eux entre l'afrique et la france
ça pète ça fait rêver ça peut réveiller
mais aujourd'hui quand vous écoutez
compte lancer des civiles africaines et
même les entrepreneurs africains
ils préfèrent davantage commercer avec
des entreprises chinoises
ruiz qatari saoudienne et est ce qui est
encore plus important
vous favorisez le mélange des
coopération sud-sud entre elles
merci beaucoup pour votre regard régie
sont occupés à la liste et géopolitiques
et directeur exécutif d'interclubs
conseil
merci beaucoup